[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
Sara brief immersion is born in South
Bronx I grew up in Brooklyn I've been
away maybe go two months yeah I've met
in California since July and then I was
in Vegas May 12th I came to Vegas that's
usually the first time I'd ever even
left New York City
because
nope I actually was found as an infant
in a trash can hours old and I was born
hustler I think I was born in a public
bathroom and throw a trash can out by
the cleaning crew and I grew up broken
home for girls yeah Brooklyn I was the
only white kids and a person within ten
blocks and when I was born I was kind of
funky
she had me on her own in a probably
bathroom so this leg was turned in like
this I just had natural that is so I had
like like the forest got Blake braces my
whole life which makes it extremely hard
I'm now coping up like Brooklyn well for
girls there was that every time minimum
hundred girls in their ages birth to 18
there was only six nuns that ran it
[ __ ] [ __ ] show complete [ __ ] show
girls were Lily like trampled to death
over food there we had at least a deft a
week every week absolutely and this was
in the 87 I'm gonna be 38 so it was
pretty morbid so now remind you I'm a
little white kid and I got hundreds of
Jewish blood and really give me um nuns
hate Jews killed Jesus right so not only
that is that I'm crippled too I mean I
was very crippled I have my leg braces
that coke bottle glasses was in the home
and I was the ugliest kid other [ __ ]
see in your life then they beat ugliest
kid ugliest kid in the world up pale
pale pale white frizzy curly hair
[ __ ] hot mess so so no but my job is
ever since birth so are having these leg
braces and everything they never like
they didn't take time to teach you
things like oh this I'll use a spoon and
this that no they so they never like
helps me go to the bathroom like potty
training stuff like that these leg
braces it was a [ __ ] to use the
bathroom and so every time I might have
an accident they'd bring me in the
bathroom shirt butt-naked and beat the
[ __ ] out of your Nina there all night
so I identified at a very young age at 3
years old that if I don't eat her Drake
that I would have accident so I wouldn't
get be it and I was diagnosed anorexia 3
years old
just from yeah just thought I didn't
want to you know they I just didn't want
any attention I just wanted to span into
the background you don't just but I was
treated leagues just kind of extremely
honestly I was also I had third-degree
burns at eight years old from a pot of
coffee that none threw at me because she
said we had personality conflicts I was
I then sent to Boston Children's
Hospital I spent three years there I was
in wheelchair for those three years they
end up reef raking parts of my body in
my back and my hips to straighten me out
and I had third-degree burns and skin
grafts or what happened boobs fake and
everything so that but you knows really
sad is arm those three years I spent
Buster's hospital I actually think those
were the best years of my childhood it's
the first time I ever had I mean I've
never had a birthday I've never had a
birthday cake ever and really I gave it
to this day but I got um Christmas
presents IDing him and I was never
allowed to participate to things like
that I was Jewish so it was pretty crazy
I was pretty wild
yeah and so it was pretty cool um you
know I survived I went through and I you
know there's one thing I walked
everywhere I don't care if I had the
nicest most beautiful car in the world I
will park that bitchin on the walk I
will walk it out cuz I know what it is
to like not be able to and I'll never
take like physical things for granted
you know like I really been compromised
more than once physically and that's
like life shorte you know if you can do
it get up and do it I mean 38 I'd had
four kids I mean it got shaved more life
yeah absolutely so you know what that I
all that now go over both girls my first
love first time I ever had sex I got
pregnant fifteen years old nobody nobody
knew I was pregnant until three days
before I had her I hit it because I was
prayed I was an orphan I was a pray the
state would take my kid and everything
else I wasn't scared
not even the kid's father you and you
know this back in the day of Jenko jeans
and the big you know sweatshirts and it
was it was wintertime so I mean I don't
I grew up on the East Coast so we had
winter it was serious yeah yeah I was
able to hide it I weighed 141 pounds
nine months probably when I went to go
have my baby my baby was seven pounds
went out that's the biggest I've ever
been in my life that's crazy all right
nine ones Brady she's perfectly healthy
I never said yeah 100% I had her got
pregnant 15 had her at 16 now mighty she
was bored all my daughters were born on
holidays as well so my oldest my first
boy I was right on her due date which
was more may 28 2015 1 so that was
pretty mind-blowing
now on my 16 birthday just before I had
her on my 16th birthday November 7th I
am aspirated myself from the state I
became my own guardian I got my driver's
license that day I aside my first
apartment lease I went to high school
that morning I worked at Pizza Hut that
night all being pregnant that day nobody
had a [ __ ] clue what I was up to and
so that was pretty cool that was pretty
epic I graduated high school a year and
a half early valedictorian of the school
the school was so and now my jobs
pregnant my second kid at that time I
got pregnant at 17 had her at 18 school
and kicked me out they wouldn't love you
Marshall the class they actually mailed
me my diploma and I was really it wasn't
really hurt by that you know well I was
breastfeeding everyone was up to problem
well everyone was graduating I was
popping out another kid you know it was
rough I had my second daughter Tatiana
Easter Sunday 2002 which was March 31st
she was amazing epic Easter Sunday she's
actually the only baby born in New
England that day was just pretty cool
yeah she liked special things like
president's critical Nastasia and then I
graduated high school I was always with
Mike his father from time I was 15 right
up until last
so--that's it was 22 years crazy love of
my life
his father of all my kids his loving my
life absolutely.i my third daughter
justice fourth of July 2004 and then I
had my last order Jacqueline Mother's
Day 2006 yeah now I did really great I
was super smart garage I have four
master degrees I did culinary
hospitality small business management
and marketing I actually own my own
dress shop in New York City custom dress
shop for about almost 15 years I also
had like catering on the side I
specialize in the expensive parties bar
mitzvahs weddings stuff like that I
still don't know I was put in the
trashcan yeah literally yeah this is
emotional support like stuff and like
one thing I remember yeah yeah literally
and I don't know how I survived it it
was crazy but uh my job is extremely
small malnourished everything you know I
mean she was a [ __ ] show now I guess my
real mother I mean her feel we had no
idea nobody had a clue it was it was
pretty crazy um yeah it was pretty crazy
and I was very not what they are members
being child is that like even now to his
day kind of [ __ ] with me is that
nothing was ever mind lately getting in
the home like there was a bit of
underwear there was a bit of shirt
there's a bit of friggin pants
we had them like jail roll out mats for
beds I wasn't allowed to touch the
silverware or there the plates or
anything because I was a dirty Jew I was
allowed to sit on this furniture I
wasn't allowed to sleep on the mats I
was
she looks like a dog when they were kid
together the kids outside to play they
hooked you into a dog runner sometimes
they leave me out there all night I'm
terribly afraid of the dark terrified of
the dark I have a issue with bathrooms
like really just weird fear I can never
close the bathroom door I've always just
got the [ __ ] kicked out of me bathrooms
and I don't want to die in a bathroom
like that it scares me that freaks me
out
never sends a small kid I just
identified that and I just say I still
to this day I mean I'll go 9 days
without eating a single thing but I
constantly drinking things but I I just
I don't I literally don't get hungry I
don't know what the sensation of being
hungry is like because I just pointed it
out you know starving it hurts too much
he just pointed out mind over matter I
do truly believe that I could manifest I
even capable of anything I put my mind
to but I just can't seem to get the [ __ ]
out of my own way lately Hey no no um I
lost my daughter's in my husband last
summer in a house fire well my husband
mind you I was a 100% square I never
even smoked Sara I've never been drunk
I've never gone out clubbing to the bars
I've never done anything in my life that
anything nothing
I don't know friends that all I did was
my family and work life alien work my
husband got really you know he stayed
home he never had a job in his life
since we was kids everything he's a
piece of [ __ ] but he was my piece of
[ __ ] my German orphan he he he didn't
leave no matter what we ever went
through he didn't leave me
and that was I was a better man issues
you know so it was really important to
me his kids bother you know it's
supposed to be meant to be a level up
whatever 19 years we were perfectly
happy we barely even had a conflict like
any source he never ever yelled his
children and put hands on his children I
mean he
was an amazing fantastic father he was
my best friend my soulmate
he was Jamaican his name is Dmytro and
he now mind you as my business grew I
got more and more busy more and more
busy and I am super Jewish very cheap I
don't wanna pay employees but I could do
it all this is your check so I mean I
was working easily 18-hour days now this
was summertime maybe two years ago
summertime
he just started getting really depressed
really different and I could tell
something was up with him but I was just
too consumed to so didn't money in my
career and this side in the other you
know I was kind of a superficial [ __ ]
to be honest with you and I decided no
time for it and I just went about my
business well I'll come to find out well
when I found out he was using drugs I
found out about crystal meth he was
slamming it and actually was living in
his neck and I then it turned into very
quickly drinking whole bottles he's
actually slamming liquor at points he
was slamming everything and anything and
his neck arm when I caught him with
drugs and a significant amount of money
I had around 140,000 in the bank and I
was down to like nine red and whatever
first time ever he beat the everliving
dog [ __ ] out of me tied me up and he's
shot me up with heroin for the first
time that's actually scarred minute
that's the one two years old and drove
to go away he did it there because he
was at this time
domestic violence started started bad it
went from zero to 100 like really quick
now Demetria is the reason we never
really like party got it's drug stuff
he's schizophrenic which he told me
about and I always knew but I never saw
like any anything alarming or anything
signs of that you know people who have
mental disorder especially like that
know he's a hard course gets a product
like scary [ __ ] like a whole other
person inside of him he took medication
he always took medication as long as I
knew him and it was never an issue and
stop taking medication start using drugs
and it just it got really bad and got
really really really bad not last summer
in the summer before so that would be
what 2017 he was strangling me daily
unconscious putting me out completely
unconscious now the thing with that is
like being strangled is something that's
very very personal you know and it comes
a point and you like you looking over
this person a minute I love more than
anything to father my children and you
accept it you stop struggling
you stop you you literally accept
whatever II was gonna have was gonna
happen that does something to you
mentally and especially I mean sometimes
it was a couple times a day several
times a day he was literally daily
putting me out strangling me and that
that's when like I really started having
a hard time and I'm kind of accepting
that the Sabbath he's gonna kill me like
this this was it you know he was just he
lost his [ __ ] mind it was crazy he
was getting a daily getting more and
more demonic the way he moved the way
his mannerisms not he says Gordon's his
episodes you know before I would be like
sometimes couple seconds sometimes
couple minutes no it certainly last days
usually between the longest ever was six
days he left me tied up in the bathroom
and he put he was playing cigarettes out
on me I have over 100 of them all over
my body and I was turned into stop like
she was hurting a Mercer which actually
almost end up killing me I hold some of
them took over a year even heal I mean I
have all of her my genitals my boobs
everything like he just he had some sick
obsession it was just seeing me in pain
and just it was just evil and like the
kids we kind of just I kept pushing the
kids away pushing the kids away and they
really didn't see much of it believe it
or not they really didn't know might do
their teenagers mica kids this year
would have been 20 18 15 and 13 so and
they just died last summer so
yeah their father set their bezel fire
while they were asleep and I he stabbed
me five times and he killed himself me
five times five times I was on life
support for months actually as well got
February 15th and they yeah I see me you
never think that huh yeah I didn't get
buried my children cuz there was nothing
left to club and it's like my whole life
I know mines you 27 years old I bought
that house I put $300,000 doubt on that
house is a half a million dollar house I
was in my dream say it was just so
beautiful it was beautiful i manifested
every little inch of it and the kids and
everything I had a dog Brody a holy dog
I've ever had in my entire life he was
17 years old he's a pit bull it's only
lived 10 to 13 years he was 17 it was
amazing the best we called he was the
only boy he was my boy he was amazing
the best dog in the world I got him when
I was 19 or my do no no no that was a
cat I got the cat in nineteen I got him
at like 23 or something like that and
justify it was amazing he died in the
fire at the foot of my middle daughter
Tatiana talk to you I was his kid he
died to put her her bed like right there
he wants to do it DYI later with her the
worst part those women scream stop you
know cuz I mean it was my daughter's the
screaming stopped because I just I knew
that that was it I listened to my kids
birth death I was tied up
how do you escape the fire I don't know
the EMTs say they saved me I don't know
why I don't know how I have no idea why
or how to the paramedics yeah I woke up
I woke up in the hospital and I thought
it had just been minutes I had no idea
and it was six months and three days
later they actually pulled the plug at
six months I know brain is nothing I was
considered clinically dead and they
pulled the plug six months
I actually remember because I can hear
the priest wherever they have come in
and like say something and I remember
that I'm unplugging and everything
I can hear and like kind of see
everything that was going on but I
couldn't respond that was the scariest
feeling in the world
I feel like trapped inside your own body
and there was different points in time I
kind of vaguely remember like seeing and
being able to hear things but I couldn't
do anything I couldn't move I can't talk
I couldn't anything and I had no idea
where I was who I was what was going on
I just I was completely lost
they pulled the plug at six months and I
just kept breathing and there's this
they were actually kinda like cracking
jokes kind of peculiar and they left out
the room and I actually just like woke
up three days later I just like shot up
and like you like jumped up and I just
kind of panicked I want to stand up and
I felt cut on my face I was 77 pounds
77 pounds and
well like this was discovered yeah 7:15
actually day after Valentine's Day yeah
I learned how to walk talk eat sleep
[ __ ] breathes everything all over
Ultra you're still reading from this
illness here here at Street West Monroe
yeah
I've never did I know we smoked a
cigarette my life until my husband shot
we had my first time and even waking up
from life support like yeah but I didn't
need it I wasn't physically addicted
anymore but the first thing I wanted to
do was I needed it I needed I need it
now mind you I never ever shot up before
in my life
so my husband always hit me in the neck
and I didn't know what to do I was a
[ __ ] hot mess actually he's a couple
Street people enough teaching me showing
me how to do it it was to kill myself
absolutely absolutely I was I was
furious that they even saved me
I had why what the [ __ ] would why he
liked it just it made no sense now mind
you now I'm in this like like rehab
rehabilitation center and in the
hospital now I'm all sudden the police
show up and they want to ask me some
questions they basically tried to turn
it all around and said that I killed my
family
and even though forensics proved that it
was impossible for me to stab myself
from those angles like the roars was
right here dad words for the state knife
a the collapse right along with it was
like just the tip of it was right on my
heart and they thought it was just kind
of it was just it was a sketchy just the
way it all went down and they went out
for some questions I just I freaked
I freaked right just out I mean not only
am i dealing with all these things like
I can't even I hadn't left the hospital
rehab like you know they told me this
you know like this is what happened to
that I don't believe you like what you
talked about this is all bad dream like
I just wanna go home I remember the
first day the first thing I did when I
left that rehab is I took the bus that I
want to go home and there there's
there's nothing left
everything's gone fastball this is
[ __ ] gone my entire life is just gone
you're literally there's nothing nothing
was salvaged nothing nothing whatsoever
it's like my entire life just now so
visit me in the hospital nobody calls me
nothing and as the domestic violence got
worse and worse like over the last like
year and a half of my marriage you know
I just alienated even more and more and
you know he's starting to hold me
hostage it nobody came to check on me
nobody nobody the police came to my
residence over 60 times for domestic
violence in a year and a half literally
over 60 times there's no reason that my
children should be done they should have
helped me they should have done
something and everyone's like whoa you
know you got to eat let them back in you
love the abuse that does [ __ ]
because that's
you can only do so much you know I've
wrote requires I put five restraining
orders on they literally drop them laid
behind my back this as an American you
have rights you don't like your everyday
rights well this is his residence this
is his address he's lived here he has a
right to be here he's means to live so
regardless of what me and him are going
through by law he's allowed to be there
because that is his residence I had to
go to the legal eviction process and
divorce him to get him out of my home
well how the [ __ ] am I supposed to do
that when he's beating the [ __ ] out of
me daily
he literally broke almost every bone in
my body literally like horrific it's
like a tattoo on my face I got a plate
at one of my face together
it's France it's crazy it's absolutely
insane I tried everything to help my
husband I truly believe that I could
save him mostly those kind of clements
because it's 19 years I mean he was a
love of my life he's literally all I
knew he was it he's my best friend he
was not he wasn't even a person anymore
he started growing to Reza day we got
married when I was 18 he started growing
his resident he had dreads passes ass he
was ripping him out of his head there's
[ __ ] like blood splatters on the
friggin ceilings and [ __ ] he was like
ripping his skin off he [ __ ] cut one
of his fingers off he was [ __ ] crazy
he was slamming bath salts at that time
and he was just completely demonic
special it's a leaky loose genic it's
kind of like Cristobal way worse and
it's just he was so he was demonic like
literally like my husband I could have
said I literally believe that he was
possessed like something took him over
he wasn't the same person anymore and
you could tell he's even despite like
looking at him and stuff and like it was
just he was completely gone hopefully
they got and after all that happened
being released whenever you have please
him more and more on my tale about
stupid things and they want to check it
with this tell you that and now my two
I've never been arrested in my life
after being held hostage in situations
and stuff like that that's actually one
of my biggest fears is being like
incarcerated or being taken like out of
my will and stuff like that I don't do
good with authority I don't do good with
feeling
I hate being vulnerable in any way any
way whatsoever late having the stupidest
things like when I'd fall asleep he
jumped on me and burned me with
cigarettes you know what I mean like I
mean when I say you're naked in the
shower what if someone breaks in you
know you're wet you slippery like what
are you gonna do you know you know
there's no window in the bathroom I
wanted to go in the bathroom you know so
like little things they seem silly but
it's literally survival to me like I
literally live every second every day
like I'm just waiting for it and it's
[ __ ] up Covina California was well and
midlifecrisis right I lost everything I
caught piss in or a window throw it out
if I'm completely broke Baker out I lost
everything my business everything um
where does everybody do their midlife
crisis they go to Vegas I was supposed
to get a sugar daddy in a new car it
didn't work out
Vegas was fun this was real I've never
seen anything quite like Vegas I really
had a blast bass I was actually doing
pretty well for myself um I was saying
on hotels like every night I was just
hustling honestly I was middleman you
selling drugs I was gambling
I'm never prostituted and I've actually
had never slept with anyone other than
my husband until just this last year
and one of them doesn't really count
because he jizz in his pants ha ha swear
to God and the other one was just a
recent thing and I mean that was fun but
uh not I just yes so that's at that
point I've never prosecuted I've never
done like really I mean dabble the drug
stuff here and there even when I was
square but that was just kind of like
you don't get some money up real quick
you know I just take a rifle with a
friend and I drop this off drop that off
and I really not much to do with the
drugs but I was I had a clean record and
I'm a pretty little Jewish girl you know
I could get away with a lot of things
that these drug dealers and these people
couldn't I have a perfectly clean record
I've had arms knighted since I was 16 I
was just very put together I was very
responsible as we're together you know
and that was one thing you know when I
was a kid it wasn't Arvind you know the
news people go around they're like oh
hey shitty orphan what do you want to be
when you grow up it's like only turtles
you know something that actually came
around over the day news guys like who
do you want to be new crop I had a leg
brace I was a little screwed I was like
a worst day ever
I remember it was raining that day and I
was I was having a really bad day and I
remember I'm like I'm not really sure
what I'm gonna be but I know every day
I'm gonna get up dress up and show up
I'm gonna be anybody I want to be and
it's funny because when my house burned
down the last time I did was I had a
little over 600 dresses I had a new
dress and heels every day
and I would I would get up every day and
like I mean I'm I'm a pretty girl and
I'm pretty but like there's I can take
it five dollars first or dress and I can
make it
I give me stop a whole room of people I
just had like a certain Flair with that
it was something about it you know I
mean a woman feels beautiful it shows
you know and I really you know just
addressing the Elle's every day you know
I've never spent more than twenty
dollars on anything anything uh there
may be a car in my house I'm super cheap
in my ways and very very thrifty but
like I'd go to like thrift store and
spend $100 and I could turn that hundred
dollars quick into five hundred but I
need a couple hours you know like
shopping is this really serious thing of
me I have four daughters at the dress
shop it was just it was my thing I'm a
journey of those dresses I'm actually in
the house burned down
they are around $40,000 is what my
clothes are worth they just loan like
it's amazing I know closet probably
about the size of this room it was
amazing like truly amazing and it was
really cool because my daughters were
now the size you like they're they're
beautiful they were Jamaican Jews like
pretty beautiful tall skinny but you
know we're all petite and everything he
knows what they were getting to the age
where they're starting to really get
into it and stuff too there's a lot of
fun it was cool to play dress-up every
day yeah I just it's crazy I really miss
my kids you know as had I see you know
especially on Skid Row
none of these women have her children
probably haven't talked to their
children
you know there is nothing in this world
that I wouldn't give just have five
moments of my kids you know I worked so
hard to make a living I forgot to live
and you know even like knowing like I
remember specific points when I knew
like I need to talk to my husband Lee
something's wrong like he needs a hug
you know huh he stayed at home
he's whatever you wanted he was kind of
yeah oh yeah I've always was the pants
in the relationship I guess but um he he
did a lot of tattooing that's pretty
much all my tattoos are from him he
didn't really do anything but he's a
credible artist definite incredible
artist and this is my best friend I
didn't care I supported him I took care
of him and you know I've never I've
never been on a date I'm almost 38 I've
never gone out to eat and not paid at
least the tip I've never had a birthday
cake I've never danced with anyone never
been to a wedding actually been to a
wedding
I've worked weddings I've never been to
an amusement park I've never been to a
cookout I've never been to a family
function they go not really know who
decided to [ __ ] of the
it was nothing I know you never my
husband never gave me anything
nothing ever not even anything and I
caught that love and it isn't about
materialistic things it's not but he
tried 140,000 in nine months and left
just everything so what my house burnt
down you know I had like all everything
on SAP on automatic bill pay and order I
didn't pick over my mail and [ __ ] you
know my house burned down I didn't have
Houston charts and nothing was I've been
paid and around about nine months and
they they're coming after me for the
cleanup of my house and just put the
cherry on top and I'm looking and I have
a bunch of outstanding it's very serious
warrants right now that if the police
get me up I could probably do life and
I've never been to jail damn my life
after all that's happened for I left New
York I mean I lost my mind a little bit
you know I really hard time I mean
everything and everything everybody I
ever know it was gone like that and I'm
northen many issues it's serious and I'm
now you know they say it's better to
love and loss unless other's [ __ ] and
I'd rather have never ever ever known
him at all you know I'd rather I don't
think I'll ever even really have sex
again like I'm good I'm done with it
these [ __ ] men dude they're
discussing you know at least honestly no
exaggeration at least five men a day hit
on me somehow some way and
absolutely but either even even before I
once he I mean just anywhere I ever was
like I even walk down the street because
she knows I'm sure you know - we walk
down the street I just go to the corner
store and I'm solicitous about some way
for sex every single time
absolutely absolutely no no absolutely
but um you know at every single time I'm
gonna you know it's annoying but not a
single one of these men asked me out to
dinner even hold a conversation with me
without mentioning their dick within the
first three minutes that's that's that's
alarming like like you're talking to the
wrong grown men
you know like that that's alarming and
like I mean I'm pretty I dress you know
I guess I'd say it's actually I'm not
really sure but I've never been like
[ __ ] you don't I mean my boobs my ass
ain't hanging out I'm not running around
here honking so like I don't understand
one thing is like what the society like
like even though the girl was talking
the other day she's like oh yeah meadow
she met this guy at a bar wherever she
went the bathroom and she sucked his
dick like I just sucked his dick and I
was like I remember like is like a bus
hit me I was like just lady she took
this so lightly oh you know it's just no
big deal I just what look one in like
three people have an STD that's not even
the infections that those diseases like
and especially here on Skid Row I hear
this out HIV like popping up weekend
right because everyone's sharing needles
and everything's going crazy and you
know that that's a very alarming number
that is very scary and you know not
everybody just you know if anybody can
have it it's no longer valuable you know
and like you can't just let anybody run
up in you through you and around you you
know you are the company you keep they
say and there's a lot of truth to that
statement you know and I keep thinking
you know I'm gonna get intent I'm gonna
do this I'm gonna do that and I feel
like if I get a 10 tonight I'm accepting
it every day I spend here I feel like
I'm less likely to ever leave and this
is really like the end of line like this
place it really truly is I'm not trying
to be dramatic it's a little late this
is the end of the [ __ ] line I have
seen some of the most disgusting most
horrendous saddest things I've ever seen
here and most heinous things
I mean I've actually was even beat up by
a bunch of guys almost gang-raped and
frigging like drug into a tent and
everything like about a month ago and
they kept me there good at least
probably 15 20 hours but like I was
terrifying
I was obviously terrified it's very
demeaning and it you know it was it was
it was awful and actually I left skid
row this actually the first time I've
come back since I've been up by the
airport lax it's like a highway of
planes I've never seen that before it's
crazy I've also have never been on the
blanket plane boat nothing like that so
it was really like funky first time I've
ever seen a palm tree was May 12th when
I went to Vegas that was pretty cool um
right now I'm not staying anywhere
I just wandered and I just keep
wondering I don't really sleep
I don't really stop I just wonder
i boost mostly to be honest um I'm very
very thrifty in my way sometimes I don't
not even S&T boots and I'm innocent
stealing you know I find things I seem
to come across things like I said her
awful mine I really think I focus on
something and it happens I kind of
figure it out like literally you know
like I found a box of uh big packs of
batteries ee is in triple-a so I have
sold them and this any other British
shoes clothing I mean you name it I
could turn around I sell I used to an
Eskimo you know that's one thing I'm
marketing to and like I was just I'm
really good at being thrifty making it
make it a dollar into ten dollars ten
dollars in this twenty you know and just
building myself up it takes me longer to
get there but I can look myself in the
mirror at the end of the day and Know
Who I am you know that's okay I don't I
don't believe in plans plans are made to
be broken
and um any moment nothing's guaranteed
nothing's you know it's everything
eventually is gonna be the last time I
don't really want friends I don't wanna
get close to anything or feel too much
at this point honestly drugs are the
only thing that makes me feel anything
and it's I was scared to come down I
can't I can't mentally deal with the
things that have happened I've never
been to a therapist I've never seen I'm
thinking me no victim system you're five
[ __ ] about me and I'm America's kid
I'm literally an orphan there was my
crazy check where's my help I've never
got a food stamp I've never got [ __ ] and
I feel some kind of way about that not
that I feel like anyone else me anything
they don't but I can't work a regular
nine-to-five at this point I can't even
stand being me sometimes you know it's a
hot mess
and
but the hair would and that's very but
I'm actually doing really good with that
I'm down to only like ten twenty dollars
a day and that's keeping me okay
I'm not great but I'm okay I'm
functioning and I know honestly in my
heart that this is a face I probably
wake up a random one more cells never
navigable for and I will probably just
stop wait like that I guarantee you
honestly are probably well I don't know
I don't know sure because I can't tell
the future but um
this isn't fun like my arms hurt they
hurt terribly I'm a freaking mess they
feels like [ __ ]
my friggin bums everything that hurts
horribly and she would not but I can
compare shooting up to
self-mutilation you know the teenagers
and like cutting themselves very much
like that because like the whole ritual
of it it's um even though my whole world
so out of control it's one thing I have
control of and it it helps ease the pain
numbness suppress and when I do get dope
sick when I when I don't have it
whatever I do it's scary I'm a danger to
myself and others absolutely extremely
suicidal extremely depressed extremely
angry hurt I can't handle loss of my
children I really can't
I still haven't cuz I never have closure
you know there's no funeral there's no
goodbye there's no they're just gone and
I miss
I appreciate
thank you
people who have come from terrible
terrible situations youth and they've
done the opposite to these people
they've accomplished things they become
great role models for their children and
they become cool people that you want to
know and that's where I think you may
fall somewhere in that's why people are
reacting the way they are we're saying
no this couldn't be real look at her
she's too beautiful it's just put
together she's well-dressed she's
articulate she's accomplished she went
you have more master's degrees in what
school I went to Boston Boston Boston
Boston but my biggest I went to classes
in Boston which really intrigued me to
push a little further because I had I
struggled now I was valedictorian in you
know in New York and froggen all's oh
[ __ ] now I was a Boston and I felt
stupid like yeah I just straight just
the community community [ __ ]
community community not the community
college but like that not Harvard yeah
but it was the link with the community
like the neighborhood kids go it was
like classes it was like puts out I
graduated from York County Technical
College which is where they sent me now
struggle very very hard in boss and it
wasn't even like a Harvard kind of
school whatsoever but I really first
semester I was ready to drop out it was
you know I graduated from New York
County Technical College in Wells me in
Wells mean this is all this is all part
of my rebuilding myself
you know I got out of New York and I
went north I graduated high school 2002
I graduated college I had a little
ceremony each year because I
accomplished those great things tonight
year but I got finished finished college
in it was Oh 8 yeah yeah I'm not his
person I was my memory my everything I
am falling the [ __ ] up I and I just
can't meet up I got this [ __ ] kicked out
or like this big [ __ ] fat chick she
just didn't like me she I literally
never seen it before in my life this is
I'm a big girl she had like a mohawk
kinda haircut tattoos all over her face
in her hair was like lime-green and she
walked by me on the dead-end road not
telling me where I was saying and she
said something like stupid [ __ ]
something something like that I was just
like what and she just I turned around
kept walking she came from behind me and
doesn't want me upside down the back of
my head and I felt fine she just beat
the everliving [ __ ] out of me and all
these people that I've been living
amongst know that my suppose my friends
right I mean no nobody did a [ __ ]
thing she like she legit beat the [ __ ]
out of me at least 15 minutes at least
late literally and just kept going and
not put my teeth out there's no phone
cops there's no calling cops anything
just anything you know any snitches get
stitches huh yeah hmm
great all right I've never been to a
dentist in my life and I had perfect
beautiful teeth and I've never bought
your dentist in my life I'm petrified
what city was your family that is in
someone's words in the absence yeah but
um they didn't get into details of
exactly his protection of you know it
was a big deal but it was um Foster's
foster daily Democrat it's all boiled
down but they didn't get into like the
address and everything they actually
protected me a lot yeah yeah absolutely
what it was I mean he killed the kids he
attempted to kill me and he killed
himself and a lot of it was um now his
family another thing you know there's
laws protecting where he where he's
deceased his family needed to be
notified before you know like there's
certain laws like like they can't you
know like say someone commits suicide or
someone commits suicide they don't go
and make it public until the family is
properly notified and then they come out
with what our article or whatever how
they're gonna point it out to the public
if we put it out to the public you know
there's a lot of things that there were
protection because of his family
I knew that and his family often also
was trying to come after me trying to
say that basically I did everything they
thought it was coincidental I've and
they're all dead and everything else now
mind you in all the years that me and
him were together his family never never
I never met his family they didn't want
nothing to do with me they were just
furious that he was with a white woman
oh really oh yeah absolutely they want
nothing to do it nothing until the day
that he dies so you know what I mean
they they're not they're not nice to me
people are not nice to me
I am automatically judged I mean right I
mean especially out in California I have
never experienced racism as much as I
have out here I have been treated like
[ __ ]
yeah I've been from one salon to the
other but I mean how the [ __ ] do I break
that how do I get out of this I mean
honestly mark I would give [ __ ]
anything just have one [ __ ] normal
day just she's like I'm breaking like I
[ __ ] going crazy I've learned you
feel like I'm losing my [ __ ] like I've
never been beat up like them but the
[ __ ] just random and just people
standing around like is it's a [ __ ]
show like it's a nobody gives up a [ __ ]
no one gives a [ __ ] [ __ ] I'm really
pissing blood it gives a [ __ ] I don't
get it I've just I'm not like that
I mean my whole entire life I've never
thrown a punch I've never been in a
fight this girl is just beaten the
[ __ ] stalks out any people laugh and
making jokes it was all in my space
every time it's exhausting it's really
[ __ ] exhausting my son was doing like
even though like I don't want to go back
there but where else I'm gonna go
literally just sit on a sidewalk
somewhere
you're doing pieces that's the point
that I'm getting at yeah you know it's
just one dick to the next and I'm going
I can't even like bring myself to sleep
with these people and then I get I was
raped
really overall I mean I can't even
butter it up any other way I was
straight out raped I mean yeah a
kick-ass dream huh no no stop because if
I did that I just get the shitty tiger
and knocked out but like there's nothing
I can [ __ ] do about it they've
literally taken all my belongings
shuffling through and kept what they
want and just throwing the rest on the
floor on the ground like they don't give
a crap here on the street in fact you're
white and you're trying to make me wanna
finish you such a hurry all you want to
do is just so-so
you're exactly who they hate so you're
gonna get absolutely and I get it every
third party for
black/white it doesn't even matter every
single angle I get it yeah yeah I really
do because I'm telling you I think I
could do three more months of this I
really can't
yeah I'm if you want to see me even a
year ago to now its alarm it's scary
drugs
I've got lucky drugs but mostly fun kid
most likely probably beating that
[ __ ] beat in there if I can rape to
death or a murdered honestly and it's to
that point like I mean I had it even
after I'm the girl beat me up the other
day and then he suffered that night he
got up I was cleaning up the duct
[ __ ] the dogs were barking dogs guys
he's got a couple dogs there anything
too and I'll clean up dog [ __ ] and I
dropped a piece and it was dark out
dropped a piece and he got out some
reason he stepped in it he [ __ ] smack
me so hard I saw he lost me to the back
at that wall he just with one cuff right
up said overhead after I'd already
gotten beat up that day and I started I
was bleeding out my ear like Liam from
slapping me so hard my was like kneeling
blade nose but was coming out my ear
what the foot leg and and once again
nobody said a [ __ ] thing
you know there's people all around cause
like 24/7 in a week this is kind of a
cheap guy to meet this [ __ ] god
like why does he's got so much pull in
power because he's nothing but a hood
booger he's nothing but a piece of [ __ ]
were you basically an unlucky person
I've never been lucky and anyway
everything I've ever got I worked for
tenfold every mistake I've ever made I
paid for tenfold like I mean every any
wrongdoing I've ever done I miss I did
have a successful business yeah but that
was really I blood sweat tears literally
I had to work hard for it the only way I
really had success at breakthroughs is
because I really suck occupy really
imporant I really am outside the box
like I can think of something I mean I
give me a pile of fabric you know making
into something amazing you know and
really what launched my business what
made my business really successful which
actually is very very [ __ ] up to be
honest with you is you know the saying
shoot your local heroin dealer I
actually got an old wifey screen
printing machine to do t-shirts and
stuff and that was actually when the
heroin thing was kind of really starting
to like show its face and my kids um
were middle school it's just starting
high school and you know it was
terrifying
you know heroines everywhere I died and
I was just god forbid you know like this
could be our kids be our kids and I
actually did this whole little like pep
rally and like rally with the kids
school and ice cream print a bunch of
t-shirts shoot your local heroin dealer
and it that's basically what bloomers
it's like what everybody like me notice
me you know like oh wow she's really on
a good track you know for daughters and
yeah the screen for it's had a bunch of
them shoot your local heroine gala
because this also might be New Hampshire
kind of a you know hillbilly age kind of
place and I was new to the area so you
know and I mean it was just something
else at the box and didn't lost my
business it really did I really came a
long way with that and now very
ironically eight years later Here I am a
heroin addict tell me that's not just
like [ __ ] really [ __ ] the the breach
of my you know success became probably
maybe my biggest downfall yeah then the
other thing that's hard to swallow is
any woman who's four kids were murdered
by her husband would break would break
and you're not you don't seem to be
broken I'm just good fake it til you
make it you know what I mean no matter
what I've ever gone through no matter
how bad I got beat up you know me put
makeup on you still show you might be a
perfect example of how resilient the
human being can be possibly but I don't
really feel it no just really just
recently increasingly lake especially
I'd say the last few months like I'm I'm
not playing mark like I'm losing it like
I'm really starting to like forget
everyday normal things even like I can't
even remember a full day and even be
with my children best care
eventually you'll be used to this
lifestyle and you will end over that's
what I'm starting to it's not good
I've debated even get getting a tenth
right so I have my own space so I could
keep my [ __ ] but I feel like if I do
that it's acceptable and if I do that
I'm gonna put all this energy and said
keeping this tent and they're done I
keep this safe it clean and this that
that I'm going to I'm gonna die enough
for content because I'm never gonna have
nothing more and that's why I just keep
pushing and pushing to just roll with
the punches hopefully I'm gonna catch a
break somewhere but I'm gonna [ __ ] to
you I'm not gonna catch no prick and
those unlucky woman you've ever met in
your [ __ ] life like everything I
could possibly go wrong in any situation
it's just it does and everyone's like
well that's because you put that out
there you put that energy out there and
I'm a firm believer the laws of
attraction and all that you know what I
mean I manifested everything in my life
we are nothing but what we've thought I
get that but it's not that I'm being
negative but it's being realistic
because I can't build myself up oh it's
gonna be a great super day but when it's
not it's gonna really crush me so I just
need to be like okay you know if it does
great but you know if it doesn't okay
you know I got to prepare myself for the
worst because that's what